you got your own
couch you got your very own couch and
and we like complimented your outfit
with the colors it wasn't even planned
oh my gosh welcome to the show
everybody all right so um what was your
first experience at The Hunger Games
because y'all are quite young and I
remember reading the books a long time
ago so what was your first experience
yeah mine I I didn't read the books
originally uh which ended up being a
blessing on this so I didn't get ahead
of myself um but I went to see them with
my family growing up every weekend they
came out and uh and then we went to the
the London Premiere a couple of weeks
ago um couple of days ago God time is
time is like a whirlwind in my head um
and and I got to introduce the film and
look up and they were in the back row
and got to kind of dedicate dedicated to
them so that was like a full circle
moment that's super cool what was your
first experience similarly to Tom it was
kind of a bonding experience for my mom
my sister and myself and we would always
go to the Barnes & Noble releases of the
books and then the Thursday night
screenings of the movies so this whole
experience has been very surreal and
strange and
weird um what about you Josh yeah um I I
well I was a terrible student uh lead
with that okay had pretty I there was a
semester I had pretty bad grades so I
had to give up a lunch period so I could
go to the library and like do study hall
we had a really good librarian there
that uh gave me the Hunger Games book
now he was lovely um he gave me the
Hunger Games book and was like read this
I promise reading's fun it's like a good
thing that you know it's it's good for
your brain and it's fun uh so yeah so
then I read it and it was I mean to his
credit it was the first book I ever read
that I couldn't put down and I'm really
kind of jump started like just reading
for me yeah yeah so it's kind of a it's
got a formative place and with me so oh
that's so cool now you're in the movie
Hunter what about you um I just remember
it being like the cool book to read in
school you know in Middle School um so I
I ended up picking it up and just became
obsessed
immediately yeah and went through all
three and then yeah and the movies like
started filming in North Carolina too
which is where I was so we were like
hearing about it filming and we were
like she got be extra did you ever I was
going to say did you ever try and be an
extra no but we wanted to oh well you
skipped extra didn't you there you go
like right there you go so Rachel I
found this crazy so you actually had to
turn down the RO at first right I did I
had just moved out to London when I met
Francis for the first time our director
and he was so keen on me doing the part
and it was such an honor cuz I was such
a fan of the book and of the character
and when he said that we were shooting
in Poland and in Germany and I had only
been in London for two weeks and I
missed my family and my friends and
stability he said that my face turned
white and he knew immediately I wasn't
going to do it um and then I kind of
caught my second wind working out there
I made a lot of friends and I felt like
I could I could do it and I I felt
confident in in my ability to carry on
for the next 6 months without my family
and uh I'm really glad I did it I'm
really glad I changed mind that's
incredible for I mean not not to down
youth I just mean it's incredible for
someone so young I was so stupid I said
yes to everything I like you know what
I'm saying like even when I was worn out
like walking neonia I still was like
okay I can do it I can do it that's so
smart I found this crazy um but I didn't
know y'all were dating before but you
did you know that she had turned down
the role whenever you accepted the like
you you got the role did you know that
yeah yeah I mean we had we had talked
about it cuz that happened a a lot
further earlier than uh than when you
started auditioning yeah cuz I I started
auditioning by the time I started
auditioning it was a pretty quick
turnaround um like I sent in the tape
and then I got the call back and then a
couple days after that they offered me
the roll and it was really one of those
things where I was like no way you know
like I didn't I I don't know it was such
a it's such a huge revered piece of like
pop culture I was oh this is maybe
they'll me and they'll put me in that
they're you know yeah that's smart too
and then I pretty much immediately
called ra I was like that thing that you
were going to do I'm going to do it yeah
you know
yeah and then she was like well wait
yeah I'm pretty sure we ended up like
officially saying yes on the same day
too cuz I remember that FaceTime call
yeah oh that's cute oh that's cool yeah
um but I I heard that you had wasn't it
like a very no no I'm sorry it was you
you had the interesting chemistry read
when
because there were a heat wave was
happening and you had no AC and you were
so I live in Brooklyn and and there was
it was last when was it last summer last
beginning of last summer and there was
this massive like unprecedented Heat
Wave and I lived in a little shoe box
apartment in New York as you do as you
do when you live here um and I had these
old AC units that all just broke the day
of our chemistry read and I've been told
I already had the job but I went into
that audition so sweaty literally and
metaphorically um sweaty uh and
emotionally that and and I went in I was
like I'm going to lose it I'm going to
lose the job that I've already got um
because I'm just like sweating I'm
dripping I can't remember the lines I'm
like oh cuz you're on zoom and you're
like trying to keep it cool I'm trying
to keep it cool and collected and and
like you know I've already jumped
through all the Hoops there are to jump
so I was like I've got this and then I
thought I hadn't and then the minute we
got on together it was like instant
magic and Rachel sang and suddenly I
forgot she lean in and start sweating
with you just nice that's how pathetic
and actor Rachel Z is like she saw the
beads and
she that's so sad so and of course like
just the universe you're like sure today
um can you explain everybody I'll go
down the rad but like explain your
characters yeah so uh I play Cory Lena
snow who fans may remember from the
original French films hor horrible then
64 years later I play him as an
18-year-old so he is a lot younger and a
little more innocent uh at least at the
beginning and then he meets Lucy gray
and his heart is on the line and that
challenges everything he thinks he knows
about control and power and by the end
he's a very very different man hell yeah
is H
yeah yeah what about your character I'm
Lucy greybeard a I am the the girl
tribute from District 12 and I get
assigned a mentor in Co lanus and
there's a bit of a romantic connection
but with a lot of asterisks after that
where you try to figure out if she's
Clinging On For Love or
self-preservation or both and uh there's
a really cool dynamic between her and
and in the games and and she also sings
so there's that I know I love the
singing in this obviously I'm a fan um
well Josh tell everybody about your
character yeah I play uh sanus plinth he
is uh one of the mentors but originally
he's from the district so he has a real
hard time Reckoning with The Hunger
Games he's very vocally against it he's
kind of the moral compass of the plot um
yeah and he meets a lot of adversity
because of it if you done that before
have you told someone that I was like
that was a very good synopsis yes Hunter
what about you um I played tiger snow
who is Cy L's cousin um technically but
they're kind of more like brother sister
also kind of like mother father for each
other because they've been uh taking
care of each other since they were we we
little children so yeah yeah I love yeah
I love y'all's Dynamic so what you two
actually bonded Hunter and Tom off
screen right y'all go like dancing right
I mean Berlin yeah we we were in Berlin
and went to some clubes Hunter and I
have a shed love of moving to music a
little bit so she's way better than I am
I was going to say you called it moving
to music which mean leads me to believe
maybe you're not a great dancer yes
exactly that's in my head I just like
move to the Beats yeah yeah yeah and is
way better but I I learned a few moves
from her you know she's she's great
that's awesome just to get to hang out I
love berin did you love it oh my God
it's the best and I I love techno so
much um and and it's also great because
you can kind of uh it's a space where
you don't it's not like you dance with
other people like you can really be in
your own Zone um but uh every once in a
while you like share a moment with
somebody and there's like this one
moment um I think where I just remember
looking over to Tom and then he looks at
me and he's got the biggest smile I've
ever seen on his face and he's going
this is
great he's moving yeah he's moving that
does mean moving to the
music I love this song
I've always wanted to do those I don't
know if you've ever done it they you put
headphones on they do it like with a lot
of house music yes that's a big thing in
England know why we love the silent
disco I think it's cuz we're all very
inhibited embarrassed people so we I'm
not I'm a very open person but I no no
but I'm saying but I would love it
because I think it's kind of nice cuz
sometimes it's annoying you go out
dancing and then someone's annoying you
and you're like I didn't come here to
dance with you I just came to dance with
me to move to the music yeah to move
like this like
Tom there we go a it's like a fast one
I've always wanted to do that though I'm
so jealous that y'all done that oh my
gosh anyway so I found this funny um I
didn't know that y'all were dating and
then I found out that you actually pass
notes this is your thing like which I
think is kind of incredible and so super
cute high school um but you pass notes
like during like on set yeah not just to
you like you just you're you pass notes
yeah um yeah yeah well I was doodling
one day in my little academy notebook
you just slide it in you just like yeah
there go so Rachel as you can see she I
think it's something cute and
then you're like a something silly she
told me to uh draw her as a flower so
you know I did this really crude drawing
of this flower with a little smiley face
on it and some legs of like delicious
anded it to her but you know what I'm
I'm glad that that became uh such a
story cuz afterwards I I got kind of
into drawing I I feel like like I got a
lot better he's really harnessed his
ability yeah and I I actually made use
something earlier yes I found out that
your favorite animal is a dog you really
like dogs I love dogs so in the same
vein of of this I decided to draw you as
a dog did you draw me as a dog it's
amazing he's so talented make sure you
show
expain well here like you are such a
great team she set that up so well I was
like okay so but there's a lot of nuance
to this drawings you see also cuz you're
cuz you're a singer so that you're
barking there's little it's in a musical
K you know the really scary part of this
the really scary part is this is after
he got better this is after he got
better um well Tom I didn't know this
but juliard you went to juliard just
like Viola Davis who by the way is so
scary in this movie like that that is
like how she said the word dull I almost
peed my pants yeah I was like don't piss
her off um anyway but I didn't know that
you both went I know I knew she went
there but I didn't know you did as well
that's amazing did we weren't in the
same class obviously yeah different
Generations but I didn't know you both
went there I just thought that was kind
of a cool thing that's an amazing thing
that you you did in your life that you
both have in common yeah I mean it's the
reason I ended up in New York which is
I'm very grateful for um but it's kind
of how we bonded on set was like talking
about you know our shared stories and
weirdly found out that we have like some
of the same teachers years apart that
have stayed there I was ask yeah one of
our movement coaches in school was the
same teacher so he' just been there his
entire existence I guess w wow that's
really cool awesome um did you ever
actually get to meet Jennifer Lawrence
anybody here for I did I think I'm the
only one I did um I we were at the the
Paris fashion week for the Dior show a
couple only a couple weeks ago yeah and
um and I didn't want to be weird and I
was just kind of psyching myself up to
talk to her um and she was so
unbelievably kind and in that clip she's
actually saying let's do another photo
where I'm strangling you saying you'll
never take my part
and and that is exactly what I wanted
from her she I love that about her she
seems like the same offscreen and on
screen truly it's amazing that's the
cool thing like working with there's so
many people in this movie too that like
Viola like that that's just amazing to
be able to work with too do you do you
get nervous in scenes with people like
that yeah I mean especially when you see
Viola's costume when she comes in with
that fake eye she scared everything it's
kind of terrifying but then she she
breaks for lunch and she's the funniest
person in the world we were just with
her this morning she's like so funny she
like immediately cuts through any
intimidation she's great I love that
awesome well what was your reaction to
the film like when you first saw it all
start with you yeah I mean um I was kind
of I was blown away I I have this thing
when I see myself or I don't believe
it's me like I think it's someone else I
have like a total disassociation from
the person on the screen good thank you
I think it's cuz I'm mental um but we're
going to go with good you're going to go
with good and pack that later what about
you I I was just I mean there there's
this like sense of relief even if you
never had a shadow of a doubt that the
movie was going to be good but we filmed
for such a long time and this movie is
separated into three parts within the
movie and it felt like we were filming
three different movies while we were
working cuz it felt like coming of age
High School also the Hunger Games also
War also this and all of a sudden it
just it came together in such a
beautiful way and it was just kind of
this oh this is a really special thing
we have on our hands we s together what
did you think well I mean I I don't know
if you remember my first reaction but
like I think I I watched the movie the
credits were rolling and I sat there for
a second and I was like I think I think
I'm going to keep
working I love
that that's good CU it looked so great
it was so great like it's something that
people are really G to get into yeah
that's awesome what about you Hunter um
the first time I saw this screening I
know it happened because it was with you
guys but I complet I have no
recollection of I I I don't know I think
maybe I went out the night before and we
were just like still going what will you
move into music were you doing Tom's
move were you utilizing I don't know I
don't remember but I had to set up a
second screening a few weeks ago before
press started because I had literally no
recollection of seeing it but I was all
I have to say is what an amazing night
before like that must have been an
incredible night before it has the
aftermath of not remembering yeah I'm
not insane I then yeah but well and also
it's I don't know it would be weird to
see her something in just something so
epic like something so big too I I would
be a little removed from that I think
too um Billy the Kid there's a new
season right yes yeah the first half of
season two at uh the beginning of of the
winter this year we're going back to
film the second half of season 2 because
of the SAG strike we got shut down um so
that will be out early next year um it's
a really fun job I really like riding
horses and I was going to say are you a
natural and a horse you like it uh so I
first started riding with when I was a
kid fell off after two lessons and
didn't get back on and then I started
again two years ago and now I love it um
oh there I am with Bill that's my horse
Bill he has a weep eye um he's like
perpetually crying for some reason and
it's not because of yeah next
challenge with my
dog wasn't that what that was kind of a
[Music]
animal
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home